The Babylon 5 reboot has been up in the
air for 12 months we're wondering was it
going to go in the CW or could it go
somewhere else I've been able to
exclusively tell you that it's looking
like it's gonna go on HBO Max
but has there been a recent big update
and a little twist to the story welcome
to Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
thank you
so if you are a Babylon 5 fan you'll
know that J micro zezinski has been
looking at doing a reimagining of his
original Baba 5 series that it would be
a complete boots up retelling of the
story he has said several times in
tweets that basically he can only sell
Babylon 5. he thought about doing other
projects doing something around it but
at the end of the day Babylon 5 is the
show that's got the name they're the
ones to the studio once so they want a
Babylon 5 show but then he actually got
quite excited about the idea of
basically if I was to tell this story
now
I think more towards the end of my
career instead of the beginning when I
first told this story
well how would I tell it differently now
I'm a much more experienced and much
wiser Storyteller what would I do
differently how would I tell the story
differently so he was not going to just
do a reboot he was going to take the
core of what Babylon 5 was and
completely reimagine the story
but the CW had first dibs and they
basically decided they wanted to push it
back a year they were being taken over
by nexta they had a lot of stuff going
on at Warner Brothers as well and there
was a quietness let's look let's wait 12
months let's see where we are next year
and then we've got a lot more chance of
producing a TV show that people actually
want
hinted a couple of weeks because he'd
have a very interesting phone call from
Warner Brothers I almost immediately
started hearing a few rumors that that
interesting phone call was because
Warner Brothers had decided they're
going to move forward to the Babylon 5
project and then they had finally got
word from the CW that they were going to
decline their option to the series
so Babylon 5 will return
it will not be on the CW
but where will it go
well
apparently according to a couple of
people I speak to
it could go to Apple TV
now
there's been a few rooms like this going
around because Apple TV are definitely
looking for content and they really want
a big Sci-Fi show they have experimented
with a few different sci-fi shows but
none of them have quite caught the
imagination of the fans
what they want is a big gong standard
television show that people will come to
Apple Plus to watch the people will
actually find apple plus And subscribe
to it to watch
they need a show like Babylon 5. now
I've been hearing rumors for a long time
that actually Warner Brothers wanted to
produce this for HBO Max
but they were always open to other
options and at the end of the day Warner
Brothers does produce a lot of
television shows and a lot of movies for
other providers they actually the Creed
movie trilogy recently is actually
produced by Warner Brothers for MGM
because MGM don't own their own Studios
Warner Brothers own one of the largest
Studio Lots in California and they rent
out a lot of that space in fact actually
renting space out on their Studio Lots
has been one of the only ways Warner
Brothers has actually kept financially
afloat in the last decade apple is
incredibly cash Rich it's probably the
only streaming service out of all of
them that is Cash Rich all of the others
either have debt or have quite large
financial problems Amazon has the debt
issues but they've also got a problem
that their business as a whole has had
nearly a trillion worth of value or
wiped off it in the last six months or
so they've also going to spend a billion
dollars on the Lord of the Rings rings
of power TV series that apparently
nobody wants
now Warner Brothers have said they're
going to produce a movie series
and that has put the rings of power
under even more pressure
so could Warner Brothers take a
something like Babylon 5 a show they own
the rights to Warner Brothers really do
have the power to do with Babylon 5
whatever they want particularly now the
option for the CW looks like it's been
declined
could they produce the CV show for Apple
well yes
if Apple are willing to order it of
course they would
um is there any precedent to this though
have Warner Brothers and apple done
deals like this before
yes
Apple have ordered a series of Speed
Racer from
um Bad Robot which is going to be
produced in cooperation with Warner
Brothers now at the moment it doesn't
look that great like it's actually going
to go ahead because apparently Apple
aren't particularly happy with a lot of
the pitches and a lot of the ideas the
Bad Robot have then come up with for the
Speed Racer series
but it does show that there's that
working relationship there already that
Warner Brothers are willing to have
conversations with apple and are willing
to work with apple and probably the
biggest television show that apple have
right now the television show that if I
say Apple TV that you'll probably think
of immediately Ted lasso is also made in
cooperation with Warner Brothers
to be honest this is not only a
no-brainer for Warner Brothers if Apple
are willing to put the money up
it's kind of logical
Apple want content like this Warner
Brothers own it but they also have
Financial issues and they kind of
wouldn't mind the income
so it's really a win-win for everybody
now my source is telling me that this is
not only a serious conversation
it's a really serious conversation
and even though this show still might
end up being HBO Max
he told me that if he was a betting man
he would put all of his money on it
appearing on Apple now that would be a
complete like really out of left-wing to
sort of change to the story it's really
not what we thought was going to happen
but really the more you think about it
the more it makes sense Warner Brothers
need money Apple have money Apple want
content Warner Brothers have content it
really is just a marriage made in heaven
it's just a deal that makes sense
let's hope whatever happens they do it
because I can tell you right now
wherever the new Babylon 5 series goes I
will subscribe and I will be watching it
and I think a lot of other people will
too but guys what do you think get into
the comments and tell me is Babylon 5 a
show good enough that you would follow
it regardless of what streaming platform
it ended up on and does this just make
business sense to you I'd love to know
exactly what you're thinking get in the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also please go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you can see most
of our new videos first and without the
adverts just for a small contribution
each month which really helps the
channel out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign foreign
[Music]